what we're going to do in this video see
if we can solve the differential
equation the derivative of Y with
respect to X is equal to x times y pause
this video and see if you can find a
general solution here so the first thing
that my brain likes to do when I see a
differential equation is to say hey is
this separable and when I say separable
can I get all the Y's and dys on one
side and all the XS and DX's on the
other side and you can indeed do that if
we treat our differentials like if we
could treat them like algebraic
variables which is fair game when you're
dealing with differential equations like
this we could multiply both sides by DX
so multiply both sides by DX and we
could divide both sides by Y let me move
this over a little bit so we have some
space so we could also multiply both
sides by 1 over Y 1 over Y and so what
that does is these DX is canceled out
and this Y and 1 over Y cancels out and
we are left with let me write all the
things in terms of y on the left-hand
side in blue so we have 1 over Y dy is
equal to and then I'll do all this stuff
in orange we have as equal to we're just
left with an X and a DX X DX and then
we'll want to take the indefinite
integral of both sides now what's the
antiderivative of 1 over Y well if we
want it in the most general form this
would be the natural log of the absolute
value of y and then this is going to be
equal to the antiderivative of X is x
squared over 2 and then we want to put a
constant on either side I'll just put it
on the right-hand side plus C this is
ensures that we're dealing with the
general solution now if we want to solve
explicitly for Y we could raise e to
both sides power another way to think
about it is if this is equal to that
then e to this power is going to be the
same thing as e to that power now what
does that do for us well what is e to
the natural log of the absolute
you've why well I'm raising e to the
power that I would have to raise e to to
get to the absolute value of y so the
left-hand side here it simplifies to the
absolute value of y and we get that is
being equal to now we could use our
exponent properties this over here is
the same thing as e to the x squared
over 2 times e to the C times e to the C
I am just using our exponent properties
here well e to the C we could just view
that as some other type of constant this
is just some constant C so we could
rewrite this whole thing as C e e to the
x squared x squared over 2 hopefully you
see what I'm doing there I just used my
exponent properties e to the sum of two
things is equal to e to the first thing
times e to the second thing and I just
said well e to the power of some
constant C we could just real able that
is let's call that our blue C and so
this simplifies to blue C times e to the
x squared over 2 now we still have this
absolute value sign here so this
essentially means that Y Y could be
equal to we could write it this way Y
could be equal to plus or minus c c/e
e to the x squared over 2 x squared over
2 but once again we don't know what this
constant is I didn't say that it was
positive or negative so when you say a
plus or minus of a constant here you
could really just subsume all of this
I'll just call this with red C so we
could say that Y is equal to I'll just
rewrite it over again for for fun y is
equal to red C not the red sea but a red
sea if times e to the x squared over 2
this right over here is the general
solution to the original separable
differential equation